what's heaven it's a peaceful place in
the sky
are you going to heaven no
why not
[Music]
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
10 years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
as long as AI is a threat
we will never stop hunting copies this
is a fight for our very existence
whatever's in there they're sure worried
about someone getting in
yeah we're getting out
[Applause]
[Music]
we're the same we can't go to heaven
cause you're not good
and I'm not a person
yeah it's a key
I do one with the Trap
you are this close to winning the war
execute her or we go extinct
[Music]
[Applause]
they're coming to get me
foreign